Die 2. Liga der Männer, sie war zumindest für ein Wochenende der Zuschauer eine Magnet des deutschen Fußballs. Seit dieser Saison neu dabei, die SV Elversberg. Außerdem steht Eintracht Braunschweig trotz einer Niederlage weiterhin über dem Strich. Kaiserslautern holt den ersten Punkt unter dem neuen Trainer Friedhelm Funkel. Darüber rede ich mit Anna, Jonas und Moritz. Viel Spaß!
Und nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Dann lass doch einmal kurz auf die Personaie Friedhelm Funkel gucken. War das für dich dann, also ein Trainer von dem Kaliber von Friedhelm Funkel, war das für dich dann jetzt genau der richtige Weg? Also weil es schreit ja schon alles sehr nach Feuerwehrmann.
Ja, ich glaube, es war völlig alternativlos, jetzt einen Feuerwehrmann zu holen. Du hast es zwei, also klar, dir geschust, da hattest du eher als Perspektiv-Trainer ja eigentlich gehabt. Und hast dann mit Kramotzis ja auch nochmal jemanden geholt, der das große und ganze auch längerfristig betreuen soll. Und nachdem zwei Trainer an dieser Mannschaft gescheitert sind, war jetzt klar, du musst jetzt einen erfahrenen Mann holen, der einfach nur bis zum Sommer – es ist auch klar kommuniziert – Friedhelm Funkel wird seine Rente mit inzwischen 70 Jahren nicht über die Saison hinaus verlängern. Und ja, nee, war alternativlos und aus meiner Perspektive oder meiner Meinung nach auch die absolut richtige Entscheidung. Anna hat der Freund im Zuge von Benjamin Kessel gesagt, dass dadurch, dass du mit Benjamin Kessel in Braunschweig diese Identifikationsfigur hast, brauchst du sie nicht zwangsläufig auf dem Trainerposten. Und in Kaiserslautern hast du halt diese Identifikationsfigur nicht so richtig auf einem anderen Posten. Auch wenn Thomas Hengen früher mal Spieler war in Kaiserslautern, der ist jetzt nicht so ein nahbarer oder zumindest nach außen hin so emotionaler Typ, wo du sagst, Herr Geheim, Thomas Hengen. Aber Friedhelm Funkel ist es eben. Und ich war am vergangenen Mittwoch bei seiner Vorstellung in Kaiserslautern und der Parkplatz zwischen Stadion und Trainingsplatz, das ist allen hätten geplatzt. Das waren in der Spitze an einem Mittwochnachmittag bei Nieselregen über 1000 Leute bei diesem Training.
Ja, also ich würde dann tatsächlich aber nachhaken wollen, weil ja, das ist jetzt eine Idee bis zum Sommer, aber du stehst ja im Sommer wieder vor der gleichen Problematik. Also du hast am Anfang gesagt, du gehst nicht davon aus, dass der FCK absteigen wird, eben auch wegen Friedhelm Funkel. Aber wenn wir dann jetzt mal auf den Sommer gucken, dann machen ja im Zweifel die gleichen Entscheider, sind wieder dafür verantwortlich, einen neuen Trainer zu finden. Hast du da so ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass sich bis dahin dann auch da nochmal was tut, dass es vielleicht auch nochmal da personelle Änderungen gibt? Und wer wäre für dich vielleicht da auch so der Kandidat, wo du sagst, okay, das könnte dann passen?
Also an Thomas Hengen, an der Personalie Thomas Hengen, wird sofern der Klassenerhalt geschafft wird, wird da nichts passieren. Ich bin aber sehr gespannt, wie es mit Enita Iri weitergeht. Nachdem wir diese Personalie in unserer Berichterstattung in den letzten Wochen auch sehr, sehr häufig thematisiert haben, ist jetzt auch die aktive Fanszene darauf angesprungen. Hat jetzt bei dem Spiel in Nürnberg auch ein Plakat hochgehalten nach dem Motto technischen Direktor hinterfragen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob er über den Sommer hinaus noch in Kaiserslautern ist. Ich glaube, es wäre gut für den Verein, wenn Thomas Hengen wieder mehr Verantwortung und mehr in den Mittelpunkt des sportlichen Geschehens rückt. Als die Trainersuche angeht, glaube ich, dass diese Situation mit dem Vertrag, also die Vertragssituation Funkel bis Saisonende kann eine große Chance sein für den FCK. Weil eigentlich, du wirst es vielleicht auch spielefeld kennen, in Kaiserslautern ist es Tradition, dass eigentlich ein Trainer beim Saisonende schon so ein bisschen angeschossen ist. Aber du gehst halt trotzdem mit ihm in die nächste Saison rein. Und meistens ist es dann im Oktober oder November dann halt so weit und er wird entlassen. Es gab in Kaiserslautern in den letzten 15 Jahren tatsächlich nur zwei Trainer, die zu Beginn einer neuen Saison neu eingestiegen sind. Und deswegen sehe ich das positiv und sehe das als Chance, dass du was neu aufbauen kannst, dass du ja unvorbelastet reingehen kannst. Aber nichtsdestotrotz steht und fällt dann alles mit der Personalie. In Köln hat ja Friedhelm Funkel, also Friedhelm Funkel hatte Köln vor, ich glaube, was? 2021, wo er sie gerettet hat. Genau, 2021. Und da war es ja genau das Gleiche. Und wer ist auf Friedhelm Funkel gefolgt? Steffen Baumgart. Und ich glaube auch, dass Steffen Baumgart eine sehr passende und vor allem auch wegen seiner Emotionen sehr passender Trainer für den FCK gewesen wäre. Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass er das gemacht hätte. Nur ist er jetzt halt aus FCK-Sicht, dummerweise seit wenigen Stunden vom Markt. Deswegen, ich will gar keine Namen nennen, weil ich auch nicht weiß, worauf es dann hinauslaufen könnte. Aber ich sehe das als Chance für den Verein.
Jonas, wie schaust du darauf, dass auch ein Verein wie der FCK da durchaus seine Probleme mitbringt?
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe zwei Brüder. Einer ist Schalke-Fan, der andere ist Dauerkarten-Hinhaber in Kaiserslautern. Das heißt, ich habe bisher schon sehr viel Leid geklagt bekommen in dieser Saison. Das Problem, das ich in Kaiserslautern tatsächlich auch sehe, ist der Druck auf dem Kessel. Der wird nicht kleiner, weil Thomas Heng hat es schon mal gesagt. Um Kaiserslautern wirtschaftlich wieder zu sanieren, muss man eigentlich in die erste Liga. Man braucht diese TV-Gelder aus der ersten Liga, weil das in der zweiten Liga nicht ausreicht. Man hat zwar diese Corona-Insolvenz gehabt, aber ich sehe da noch einen sehr, sehr weiten Weg. Und wie der Moritz das schon richtig gesagt hat, also es ist völlig offen, was im Sommer passiert. Ab und zu geistert immer wieder der Name Stefan Kunz durch die Gegend, was auch wieder so eine Identifikationsfigur in Kaiserslautern wäre. Aber wie gesagt, das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen, was da passiert, eben weil auch so viele Emotionen an diesem Verein dranhängen. Aber ich sehe es auf jeden Fall noch einen ziemlich langen Weg, bis in Kaiserslautern der Druck des Erfolgs mal ein bisschen abnimmt, bevor man wieder wirklich in Fahrwasser kommt, wo man wirklich locker planen kann quasi. Also bevor da wirklich wieder mal ein bisschen Druckabbau da ist. Und ich glaube, man hat es auch gemerkt an der Entscheidung, die man mit der man Antwerpen damals entlassen hat und Schuster eingesetzt hat. Also der Druck ist extrem hoch in Kaiserslautern, irgendwie zum Erfolg zu kommen, um diesen Verein am Leben zu erhalten. Und ich glaube, der wird auch in den nächsten Jahren mit kleiner.
Bei Marco Antwerpen finde ich ja sehr interessant, dass er jetzt Trainer bei Waldorf-Mannchen ist.
Zusammen mit Terence Boyd.
Das ist einfach eine sehr schöne Connection. Anna, wie ist das bei dir? Wie schaust du auf den FCK? Ja, wie überrascht bist du vielleicht auch ein bisschen, dass die da so weit runter eingerutscht sind?
Nicht so sehr, muss ich sagen, weil es irgendwie ein sportliches Niveau ist, auf dem ich das Team eher verortet hätte als eins, das ja mit uns zusammen aufgestiegen ist aus der 3. Liga. Und das ist noch nicht so lange her. Und ich finde, dass die Vereine einerseits so mit ganz anderen Themen zu kämpfen haben, aber glaube ich, ich meine, das kennst du ja aus vielem Feld ja auch, dieses Lied dieses, da geht es wirklich, wirklich um den langfristigen Erhalt des Vereins. Wenn wir darüber reden, Klassenerhalt in der 2. Liga oder nicht, weil die 3. Liga langfristig die 4. Liga bedeutet. Also das sind keine Vereine, die sich etablieren werden in Liga 3, dafür sind sie zu groß. Also zumindest ist mir da bisher kein wirtschaftliches Konzept plausibel gemacht worden, was da diese Schrumpfungen gesund hinbekommen würde. Und ich glaube, das verbindet Eintracht Braunschweig mit dem 1. FC Kaiserslautern, die ja noch viel erfolgreicher in der Historie gewesen sind im Vergleich zu uns. Aber dieses, wenn wir absteigen, dann geht es halt wieder einfach um alles. Und deswegen, weiß ich nicht, Moritz, ob du mir dazu stimmen würdest, aber empfinde ich den Kampf um den Klassenerhalt in der 2. Liga immer auch als existenziell, auch wenn es so ein bisschen, man nimmt es mit Geigenhumor, man versucht da irgendwie, ja, den Mut nicht zu verlieren oder den Kopf nicht in den Sand zu stecken oder welche Reden zwar dann auch immer angemessen sein könnte, aber am Ende des Tages ist es halt wirklich kein Spaß. Also ich fand das vorhin ganz schön, Jonas, wie du gesagt hast, ich dachte, das ist hier irgendwie totale Stahlraffenland und ich habe immer nur Angst. Liga ist wirklich, ich will jetzt auch gar nicht in deinen Wunden rühren, Eva, aber es ist nicht so schlimm. Und ich glaube, das geht den Leuten in Kaiserslautern genauso.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist eben auch ein ganz großes Problem von Erwartungshaltung. Also was für einen negativen Kredit vielleicht einfach Traditionsvereine mit sich bringen. Also ja, SV Elversberg sieht sich vielleicht langfristig 2. 3. Liga und Kaiserslautern sagt, wir brauchen die Bundesliga eigentlich. Ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, der Bielefeld ist nicht geschafft, zumindest ein Jahr in der Bundesliga zu sein. Es wird noch schlechter aussehen, aber man hat eben das Geld auch damals viel zu schnell verprasst, was dadurch entstanden ist und weil es Corona war etc. Ich meine, dass Vereine sowieso viel zu schlecht aufgestellt sind. Ich meine, da brauchen wir uns nur die komplette Situation gerade anzugucken. Aber ich finde es eben doch so interessant, wie viel dann eben auch gerade, wenn es um Trainerentscheidungen geht, wie viel da dann getrieben wird und wie viel man dann sagt, okay, wir stecken jetzt doch spontan Geld da und da rein und machen so. Es sind eigentlich Panikkäufe. Also, alles schreit irgendwie nach Full-Panic-Mode. Und wir müssen da irgendwie möglichst schnell rauskommen. Und wir denken zwar nicht von Spiel zu Spiel, aber wir denken gerade mal von Halbserie zu Halbserie. Und das ist, glaube ich, so was, was einen Kaiserslautern ein, einen Braunschweig vielleicht auch ein, einen Bielefeld ein. Ja, wahrscheinlich auch momentan, wenn wir auf Schalke 04 gucken, etc. Das ist alles was, und was vielleicht dann bei einem VfL Osnabrück, auch wie in Wiesbaden, SV Elversberg, vielleicht nicht so der Druck ist, dass man sagt so, ja, okay, bei uns war jetzt in der Finanzplanung nicht komplett eingerechnet, dass wir jetzt fünf Jahre 2. Liga spielen so und mit Aussicht auf Bundesliga. Und ich glaube, es ist ein riesengroßes Problem. Und ja, da bin ich tatsächlich sehr gespannt, wie Kaiserslautern das jetzt auch löst.
Wer den FCK in der 3. Liga gesehen hat, gerade in den Jahren, wo es dort sportlich nicht lief, es war ja so trostlos, dieses tolle Stadion. Und dann sind da 16, 17.000 Zuschauer und das ist irgendwie. Und wer diesen Verein jetzt wieder sieht, mit einem Zuschauerschnitt von über 40.000 Leuten. Und diese Erwartungshaltung, ja, die ist immer groß in Kaiserslautern, aber die ist jetzt nicht so, dass es heißt, wir müssen unbedingt aufsteigen. Ich glaube, viele im Umfeld des FCKs finden es aktuell so rein von der Konstellation, welche Mannschaften in der 2. Liga spielen oder hin besser in der 2. Liga zu spielen. Und wenn du dort eine erfolgreiche Saison – und erfolgreich sage ich jetzt mal, du landest am Ende vielleicht auf einem 7. Platz oder auf einem 6. Platz – wenn du sowas mal wieder spielst, dann macht es den meisten vermutlich sogar viel mehr Spaß, als wenn du in der Bundesliga spielst, wo du realistisch gesehen völlig auf die Ohren kriegst und dich vielleicht mit Ach und Krach irgendwie auf den 15. oder 14. Platz oder so retten kannst. Und um Anna nochmal aufzugreifen, falls es tatsächlich dieses Jahr doch am Ende runtergehen sollte in die 3. Liga, wird es finanziell auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr düster aussehen. So allein jetzt in der 2. Liga ist das jährliche Defizit im Bereich von 5 bis 7 Millionen Euro, das durch Investoren ausgeglichen wird. Jonas hat im Grunde recht, eigentlich trägt sich das Ganze nur in der Bundesliga. Es würde sich vermutlich auch in der 2. Liga tragen, wenn du halt in der Fernsegel-Tabelle der 2. Liga relativ nach oben springen würdest. Aber das ist halt ein Prozess, der 5, 6, 7 Jahre dauert, bis du irgendwie 18 Mannschaften oder zumindest 14, 15 Mannschaften im TV-Wanking überholt hast.
Ja, lass uns einfach ganz kurz auf die nächsten Spiele des FCK schauen. Auch da zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe, dann auch auswärts bei Rostock und zu Hause gegen Osnabrück. Also gerade Rostock und Osnabrück sind wahrscheinlich auch wieder diese, okay, die muss man gewinnen. Also da reicht kein Punkt, da hilft ein Punkt einfach überhaupt nicht weiter, gerade wenn man schaut, wie eng es da unten drin auch ist.
Du hast, du hast vorhin was Gutes angesprochen und du hast dich so ein bisschen gewundert über die Pokalspiele unter Kramozis. Es ist ja so eine chronische FCK-Krankheit seit vielen, vielen Jahren, dass in den besonderen Spielen, seit es Pokalspiele oder seit es Ligaspiele wie jetzt gegen Schalke, gegen Hamburg, gegen Hertha, das sind den Spielen, diese Mannschaft ganz anders auftritt als in Spielen gegen die vermeintlich kleine. Jonas wird es wissen, der FCK hat gerade in Elversberg verloren. Und das ist ja einfach, das ist ja eine Frage des Mindsets und der Einstellung. Und da ist jetzt halt Friedhelm Funkel gefragt. Und ich glaube einfach, dass er mit seiner Erfahrung von über 800 Spielen als Trainer in der ersten und zweiten Liga einfach weiß, wo er da ansetzen muss. Weil klar, du musst auch die Defensive in den Griff kriegen, der FCK hat mit 43 Gegentoren die zweitmeisten der Liga kassiert. Aber viel wichtig ist, ist es einfach in die Köpfe der Spieler reinzukommen und denen klar zu machen, dass es jetzt auch gegen Osnabrück, gegen den Letzten, dass du da nicht überheblich rangehst und denkst, ja wir sind ja der große FCK und wir gehören da unten ja eigentlich nicht hin, sondern wir gehören ja eigentlich viel weiter oben hin. Weil das ist eine wahnsinnig gefährliche Einstellung. Weil der FCK ist nie abgestiegen, egal ob aus der Bundesliga, der zweiten Liga, ist nie abgestiegen, weil er super schlecht war, sondern weil er nie, weil er nichts aus seinen Möglichkeiten gemacht hat. Und so ähnlich ist es dieses Jahr auch wieder. Und das Derby gegen KSC nächste Woche wird jetzt halt auch für die Stimmung im Umfeld enorm wichtig. Das erste Heimspiel von Friedhelm Funkel gegen Karlsruhe. Wenn er das gewinnt, dann könnte das schon wieder so eine Initialzündung sein, die den Verein und die Mannschaft einfach durch die nächsten Wochen trägt.
Ja und man ist ja eben noch im DFB-Pokal dabei. Also lass dir jetzt mal den Run aufbauen und dann lass dich noch im DFB-Pokal weiterkommen und hinterher vielleicht sogar im Finale stehen. So ist natürlich immer irgendwas zwischen Chance und ja auch immer so ein bisschen natürlich auch Risiko. Hinterher verlierst du das Halbfinale, last minute, das verletzt dich noch irgendwer und dann stehst du natürlich doch wieder mit nichts da. Ich finde es einfach eine sehr interessante Geschichte, die auch der FCK jetzt diese Saison oder die letzten zwei Jahre genommen hat.
Ich finde es gerade in dem Zusammenhang, dass jetzt unter Umständen Saarbrücken, wenn sie gegen Gladbach gewinnen oder halt der FCK die Chance hat, ins Finale einzuziehen. Unter diesen Umständen finde ich es einfach so schade, dass es die Regel nicht mal gibt, dass der Pokalverlierer den Europapokal Platz bekommt. Dann hätte diese ganze Pokalsaison doch nochmal einen ganz anderen Charme oder auch selbst für Mönchengladbach, die halt irgendwie ihre Saison damit nochmal retten könnten. Weil gehen wir realistisch ran, selbst wenn der FCK 1 Finale kommt und dort auf Bayer Leverkusen trifft, dann ist der FCK der Verein der Bayer Leverkusen die erste Saison niederleitet.
Ich bin da auch ganz ehrlich, also nach den letzten zwei Pokalsiegern wäre es uns auch verdient, sowas wieder einzuführen. Aber es ist nur meine persönliche Meinung. Generell muss ich echt wieder sagen, diese Liga schafft es immer wieder, mich dermaßen zu überraschen. Ich wäre gerne weiterhin Teil von ihr. Ich bin immer ein bisschen neidisch auf euch, trotz allem, trotz Existenz, Hans. Ich mag es einfach, dass es eben doch so ist, dass auch für Aussteiger die Chance ein bisschen mehr da ist, sich irgendwie zumindest für ein Jahr oder für zwei Jahre mal zu etablieren und da irgendwie ein bisschen Luft zu schnappen. Das finde ich schon irgendwie ein bisschen angenehmer und ich hatte ganz am Anfang angesprochen, letztes Wochenende war die Bundesliga, hatte glaube ich einmal das Eintrachtstadion mehr an Zuschauerinnen als die Bundesliga. Klar, kann man natürlich auch diskutieren, woran das liegt, aber ich finde es trotzdem irgendwie auch stark, dass trotzdem so viele Leute zu Schalke gehen, zu Kaiserslautern gehen, zu Braunschweig gehen und Co. obwohl vielleicht nicht immer alles glatt läuft, obwohl vielleicht nicht alles passt und ich finde das einfach ein sehr, sehr schönes Zeichen für, ja, was fanlieber eigentlich auch ist.
Ich finde es ganz interessant, dass dieser Rekord noch nicht mal unter, ich nenne es jetzt mal, optimalsten Bedingungen aufgestellt worden ist, weil der FCK hatte ja zum Beispiel gar kein Heimspiel und in Kaiserslautern wären roundabout nochmal 10.000 Leute mehr gewesen als jetzt bei dem Spiel in Nürnberg.
Ja, also wir hatten vorhin, ich glaube, auch 8.000 Leute bei Elversberg, bis hin zu 60.000 Leute bei Schalke gegen Wiesbaden, wirklich alles dabei. Und das ist schon, also, ja, um da natürlich auch nochmal ganz klar zu sagen, das ist eben auch doch das Herz und die Seele des deutschen Fußballs. Und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr schön. Möchtet ihr noch irgendwas zu den drei Vereinen sagen? Trinken noch was los während zur Lage der Liga? Ja, Kinder.
Ich glaube, es wäre für den FCK besser, das Halbfinale zu Hause gegen Gladbach zu spielen als in Saarbrücken. Klingt jetzt vielleicht im ersten Moment komisch, weil du hättest einen Erstligisten oder einen Drittligisten zur Wahl. Aber in Saarbrücken wäre so ziemlich das unangenehmste Spiel, was den FCK treffen könnte, obwohl er eigentlich in den Drittliga-Jahren eine sehr gute Derby-Bilanz hatte gegen Saarbrücken und kein Spiel verloren hat. Aber so oder so sage ich natürlich, der FCK kommt ins Finale, aber realistisch gesehen muss er sich dort einfach auf einen schönen Tag freuen und alles andere ausblenden.
Allein schon wegen dem Rasen wäre es wahrscheinlich besser in Kaiserslautern.
Aber der wird ja gerade ausgetauscht.
Eventuell ist er bis Sonntag aber nicht fertig. Und mein Verein spielt ja am Sonntag. Wir wissen noch nicht, ob wir vielleicht nach Frankfurt müssen stattdessen. Ist auch quasi die gleiche Strecke von mir.
Schwimmwesten mitnehmen.
Ja, gut. Sind wir ehrlich, das hat auch keinen großen Einfluss auf den Fußball, der hier gespielt wird. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Aber nochmal, um auf Annas Frage zurückzukommen, es wäre ja eigentlich kein gutes Oben, wenn der FCK den Pokal wirklich gewinnen sollte, weil Abstiege und Pokalsiege in einem Jahr, damit kennt sich der FCK ja ganz gut aus.
Ja, und so schön, als Oben-Liga-Pokalsieger da dann nach Europa zu fahren.
Ich glaube sogar, durch die Einnahmen, die du dann durch die europäischen Spiele kriegst, könntest du auch wirtschaftlich den 1-Jahr-3. Liga wieder ganz gut abfedern. Aber ich glaube, das will keiner.
Es ist tatsächlich ein Verein dabei, wo man wenig Vorstellungen hat, wer die momentan schlagen soll. Aber wenigstens auch mit sehr schönem Fußball. Ich finde, das ist ja, womit ich dann klarkommen kann, tatsächlich als neutrale Beobachterin. Gut, ich fand es ein sehr schönes, vielleicht auch kitschiges Fußball-Pledoyer zum Ende und möchte als allererstes kurz noch ein paar Service-Mitteilungen hier in die Runde laufen. Heute ist ein Schwerpunkt zur SGE mit Stefan Reich und Max erschienen. Am Ende der Woche erwartet euch dann noch eine weitere Ligatur zu den europäischen Ligen und der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt weiterhin werbe- paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Unterstützt bitte den Rasenfunk, um die Arbeit, die Max hier wirklich wöchentlich leistet, auch ein bisschen zurückzuzahlen, wenn ihr könnt. Und bevor ich euch hier gleich bedanke, meinen Gästinnen, möchte ich kurz auf einer neueren Person hinter den Kulissen danken und ein paar Worte widmen vielen Dank an Moritz für die Hilfe bei der Organisation dieser Folge. Das macht wirklich sehr, sehr vieles entspannter, zumindest für mich, sodass ich dann auch am Wochenende in Ruhe in den Stadion gehen kann und weiß, dass das ist irgendwie alles geregelt. Das ist eine sehr, sehr wertvolle Unterstützung. Danke an der Stelle. Und dann möchte ich natürlich auf diese Runde danken. Vielen lieben Dank an Anna. Schön, dass du dabei warst. Schön, dass du uns alles über Braunschweig erzählt hast. Danke, dass du da warst. Ja, lieben Dank auch an Jonas. Es war ein Debüt, als würdest du nichts anderes tun. Ich glaube, alle haben so ein bisschen mal die SV Elversberg jetzt kennengelernt. Sehr schön, dass du auch da mit am Start warst.
Vielen Dank, dass ich dabei sein durfte.
Und zum Schluss auch Danke an Moritz Kreilinger. Danke für dein Know-how zum FCK und für den Hottag direkt zu Beginn. Vielen Dank.
Es war mir eine Freude mit euch. Und ich freue mich auf die Spezialfolge zum DFB Pokalfinale.
Gott, Max wird mich umbringen. Dann, wie gesagt, nochmal der Hinweis. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk. Ich wünsche euch noch eine schöne Restwoche. Und habt ein schönes Wochenende auch schon mal.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.